it's the first christmas night
having traveled hundreds of miles for
many days
three wise kings from the east have come
to bethlehem
following a bright star in the sky they
know this star signifies the coming of
the new king of israel
in a small barn a family joseph mary and
their new baby jesus are surrounded by
shepherds and their animals who have
just witnessed the miracle of jesus
birth
the three kings come to join the group
and offer gifts of gold frankincense and
myrrh
and they pay homage to jesus
recognizing him as christ the messiah
at least that's the story we are told on
christmas day but this picture is not
quite right
according to the original tale told in
the gospel of matthew the three wise men
didn't come until after jesus was born
traditionally it is thought that they
showed up after 12 days
hence the 12 days of christmas
also the story of the shepherds
worshiping jesus isn't mentioned in the
gospel of matthew but in the gospel of
luke
and that does happen on the night of
jesus's birth
the combination of these events in the
traditional nativity scene is a
convenient artistic convention
okay what else is wrong
well
how many wise men were there
the gospel account states now when jesus
was born in bethlehem of judea
in the days of herod the king behold
there came wise men from the east to
jerusalem there is no mention of the
number of wise men
in the western christian tradition it's
assumed there are three matching the
number of gifts
which seems reasonable to me
but in many parts of the eastern
christian world there are thought to
have been 12 wise men
okay
the wise men didn't show up on christmas
day and we don't know how many there
were
but hang on there's one more problem
since when were they called kings
[Music]
while the three gift givers in the
christmas story are often called kings
there is no indication that they are
rulers of any kind in the gospel
narrative
the supposition of their royalty started
appearing in the 3rd or 4th centuries
experts assumed they started to be
referred to as kings because of passages
in the old testament specifically in the
books of isaiah and psalms the gentiles
shall come to your light and the kings
to the brightness of your rising
the kings of tarshish and of the isles
shall bring presents
the kings of sheba and seba
shall bring gifts
this characterization of them as kings
continued into the medieval period and
in many respects continues today the
kings were even given names and
countries of origin which they
presumably were rulers of depending on
the tradition their names changed but
the western church eventually settled on
melchior
casper and balthazar
malchior is usually depicted as an old
white-haired king of persia
casper is middle-aged and is usually
said to be king of india and lastly
balthazar is a young dark-skinned man
and a king of arabia
though in later traditions is commonly
said to be an ethiopian king
i should point out that all of this is
just the most common interpretation
what the king's names are their ages and
places of origins are all pretty
malleable because well it's all made up
well all of these conventions and
traditions are interesting it falls on
me to point out that they are all wrong
or at the very least completely
unfounded for one the men weren't kings
clearly they were men of some importance
as they do visit king herod before
visiting jesus and not just anyone could
get an audience with the king after all
but the gospel doesn't say that they are
royalty of any kind secondly they aren't
from separate kingdoms when they leave
judea the bible says
they departed for their own country
singular another way
so okay who were these men
well it's actually not hard to figure
out
in most english translations of the
gospel the men are referred to as wise
men
but if we look to the original greek we
see the word used is magi
[Music]
magi was the name given to zoroastrian
priests
zoroastrianism was a major religion in
the ancient world practiced mostly in
persia which at this point was part of
the parthian empire
its founder the prophet zoroaster
sometimes called zarathustra taught that
there was one supreme god named ahara
mazda meaning wise lord and one evil
entity named angra manu
these two deities were said to be in a
constant lock struggle
good versus evil and the message of
zoroaster and his later followers was to
always take the side of good of ahara
mazda
as you can probably see this sort of
cosmology was very influential to
christian theology and helped promote
the devil a character rarely seen or
even discussed in judaism and make him a
central figure in christianity
anyway in the greek speaking world magi
were quite well respected as sages and
above all else astrologers which makes
sense as the biblical magi were said to
have followed a star to jesus
this respect for magi may well be why
they are included in the gospel account
though there is probably more to it than
that
see the writers of the gospels were very
well acquainted with the old testament
scriptures and made constant references
to them
this story in the gospel of matthew is
making reference to the book of numbers
the fourth book of the hebrew bible in
numbers there is a character called
balam
he is a priest and a diviner from persia
hired by the moabites a tribe of people
blocking the jews from the promised land
he is ordered to set a curse on the
israelites but ballan doesn't do that
after he has a vision from the god of
abraham balaam blesses the israelites
instead and gives a prophecy
i see him but not now i behold him but
not near a star shall come out of jacob
a scepter shall rise out of israel so
the author of the gospel of matthew is
asserting that these magi are coming to
fulfill that prophecy
also many medieval theologians like
saint ambrose linked the magi with
balaam they saw the zoroastrian magi as
coming from the same tradition as balaam
in fact some christians claimed that
balaam and zoroaster were actually one
in the same
though this was not a majority opinion
so those were the wise men
but what about those gifts
[Music]
the wise men were said to give gifts of
gold frankincense and myrrh to the holy
family
gold everyone understands
but what are frankincense and myrrh and
what do they mean
well on a surface level like gold they
were very valuable products
frankincense is a natural resin that was
usually used to make incense and myrrh
is similarly a natural resin but was
more commonly used to make essential
oils
basically they were both very precious
materials used by the wealthy but the
gifts may have had symbolic meaning as
well
the gold was meant to represent christ's
kingliness frankincense which was used
by the jews in religious ritual was
meant to represent christ's godliness
and finally myrrh which was often used
in embalming and to prepare dead bodies
for their funerals represented christ's
mortality an eventual sacrifice
traditionally it was said that melchior
gifted the frankincense balthazar gifted
the myrrh and casper gifted the gold but
again none of that is in the bible
account
whether there were three wise men or
twelve whether they were kings or
astrologers or priests what really
matters is that their story gave us my
favorite christmas carol
see you next time and happy holidays